hey everybody it's Mike for you here
with on call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
ia.l2-3.5.7 and force a minimum password
complexity and change of characters when
new passwords are created
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor is
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all this cmmc dfars
and nist SP 10171 compliant stuff on top
of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions and we can help you transform
into your company's on-call compliance
Hero Let's jump into it
cmmccontrolia.l2-3.5.7 and force a
minimum password complexity and change
of characters when new passwords are
created okay pretty straightforward on
this one but again remember not
everybody understands the concept of
Group Policy yes you can for sure set a
group policy rule to enforce this but
what about everyone with individual
computer systems right what about those
it still has to be enforced thankfully
many of Microsoft cloud systems such as
Office 365 GCC high and other common
systems mostly come with this configured
however you must verify this is the case
anywhere cui is stored so again remember
this is for systems where cui are stored
you just can't assume that password
complexity is turned on everywhere
without checking or you will look a
little silly when your CEO's password
shows up as
password
let's see exactly what the assessors are
looking for on this one
four things you're looking for number
one determine a password complexity
requirements are defined uh and again
easiest place to Define this is going to
be in group policy you can certainly do
it other ways but to give you one sample
answer we'll just say hey looking Group
Policy two determine if password change
of character requirements are defined
this is implemented via again Group
Policy right so we'll Define the number
of days very important okay we have had
Auditors come back and say hey you
didn't tell us how many days in your
system security plan so I'll just throw
it through a random number like 45 days
determine if minimum password complexity
requirements are defined and enforced
when new passwords are created okay this
is implemented via Group Policy minimum
of 12 characters okay just an example
you don't have to use 12. uh determine
if minimum password change of character
requirements as defined are enforced
when new passwords are created kind of a
funny one to throw in there but yes it
is important to make sure your group
policies are actually enforced so they
will test that okay that's probably a
controller they're going to test all
right now if you are looking at all of
this and scratching your head and maybe
something else and trying to figure out
what in the world you're going to do
about all of these controls here's the
good news at on-call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be prop be
a proper on-call compliance hero for
your company eliminating gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you visit cmmc
complianceecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliances roll
it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
and hit us in the comments below to let
us know what you'd like to know more
about when it comes to information
security and compliance and I'll see you
on the next one
foreign
[Music]